so on tuesday donald trump did this
video screed where he
had sort of like conflicting and
confused reasons for which he was
threatening to veto the second
coronavirus stimulus package
on wednesday he did veto that package
and one of the things donald trump said
he wanted
is a two thousand dollar stimulus check
rather than a six hundred dollar
stimulus check now very conveniently
many democrats inc including our friend
ro khanna
have been talking about two thousand
dollars per person for a while
and as soon as donald trump said i want
two grand many democrats said great
let's work together on it we're ready to
do it
but the republican party has blocked an
attempt democrats did move to increase
the size of the checks when
trump said let's do two thousand and
um it is not going to happen because
yesterday house republicans
blocked the attempt by democrats to do
two thousand dollar payments and now
we are simply waiting on whether the
house will vote to
override trump's veto on monday and
whether if that happens
the senate will vote to override trump's
veto
on tuesday um but
it is uh it's just not going anywhere
the republican party has been arguing
for
less and less money and uh the house
tried to pass two thousand dollar
payments
on uh christmas eve day so yesterday
during the day
they had a brief meeting of the house
where um democrats tried to approve two
thousand dollar payments by unanimous
consent which means any one lawmaker can
block it it's not
a 50 plus or super majority or whatever
uh
it is simply um any one republican any
one lawmaker can block it
uh congressman steny hoyer democrat
offered the proposal from the floor
and it was blocked by house minority
leader
kevin mccarthy and that is it
uh so we there's really no expectation
at this point that that is going to
happen
um under trump's watch house speaker
nancy pelosi
said that on monday she will do a
recorded vote on the two thousand dollar
payments but
i mean it's not going to make any
difference at this point in time
democrats continue to tell trump just
sign the bill
and um let's uh
i mean listen one of the other problems
here is why
is the government funding bill part of
the same vote
as the coveted stimulus bill we know why
this is a common thing that's done
in in congress the idea is if you're
against a bunch of stuff one party wants
to do
you say let's join this vote with the
stuff we want to do
you do one vote for both bills and then
20 years later much like we've seen
happen with bernie and joe biden and
others when you're asked
why did you vote in favor of bill a and
you say listen
i wasn't really in favor of bill a i was
in favor of bill
b but our colleagues on the other side
said the only way they would support it
is if we wrapped it up with bill a
i found it so important to get the
people six hundred dollars instead of
zero
that i conceded i said i'll give them
bill a because they're giving me bill b
which i think is the right bill for for
helping people this is politics this is
how it always works
it's disgusting there's no actual reason
that you couldn't have
one vote on covet stimulus and then
separately
one vote on government funding but that
is the way that they have done it
and um one of the interesting sort of
little details is we talked yesterday
about how donald trump has turned
on basically everybody around him mike
pence
uh mike pompeo he's he believes none of
them are supporting him in his
bid to overturn the election results
mitch mcconnell's also on that list
and mitch mcconnell has been against
more stimulus for months
and when it's a conversation about
stimulus he wants the
smallest possible stimulus since trump
suggested the two thousand dollar
payments
mitch mcconnell has been silent uh
about the demand for the two thousand
dollar
payments um and it is just
you know the who really loses here it's
the people
right and this is why when we talk about
political posturing by either side when
we talk about
um all of these different
public moves that do nothing to actually
get help to people to be any closer to a
reality
um we we have to remember that a bunch
of this stuff
is almost almost as bad
on the democratic side as the republican
side
so we'll see what happens monday with
the house vote on overriding trump's
veto
we'll see what happens tuesday
conditionally with the senate
voting to override that same veto and
maybe by mid-january payments could be
going to people it will take
uh a couple at least a couple of weeks
it is believed
once if and when this is approved for
money to get into anybody's hands so
certainly
2021 not this is not going to be 2020
money
in the best case uh at all we've got a
great program for you today we will be
off all of next week the show will be
off next week just reminding everybody
no
show next week and then we will be back
with you in the new year but we still
have
plenty going on today remember that
on a january 1st 1 121
we have a huge membership special going
on
if you want to be notified about it just
get on my newsletter at davidpakman.com
um it is this is a the type of
membership special
people have never even heard of before
nevermind seen
alright so get on that mailing list at
davidpakman.com quick break
much more one of our sponsors is
privacy.com they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy the virtual card number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank
or credit card info protected against
data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a 10 a month plan
that gives you one percent cash back and
lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman